We're starting with the outlier
data Excel file brought in.
Next, we have the scatterplot tool
setting the h field as the x field, and
the income field as the y field.
Then we click on plot elements tab,
and deselect the smooth line option.
Finally, we'll add a browse tool to the
output of the scatterplot tool, run it,
and let's see what the plot
looks like using all the data.
Next, to remove outliers for
the people over 60,
we're going to add a filter tool and
select age less than 60.
The true side of the output will filter
out the records where the age is less
than 60.
There are 11 records
that meet that criteria.
So now let's add a scatter plot tool to
the filtered data stream, and configure
it like we did before, and then add
a browse tool to see the results.
Let's review the first
scatterplot again,
there are three outliers
in the scatterplot.
The slope is actually steeper
without the outliers, therefore,
the outliers skewed the model
in a downward direction.